[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's meine
beiden bzw exporte und zwar habe ich mir
das überlegt mit einer fruchtigen creme
ich weiß traditionell oder bzw so
typisch sind darin pistazien und so was
ich habe mir gedacht das was ich mache
das mag wirklich jeder jeder der
fruchtige es mag jeder der seine mag und
jeder der leckeren vanille biscuit markt
personen dort habe ich nämlich
ausgedacht für euch ich habe es gelesen
schon mal gemacht gebacken und probiert
und es war super lecker und jetzt zeige
ich euch die zubereitung ich wollte euch
noch mal ganz kurz erzählen dass ich
oben auf der torte einem mond sich hier
gemacht habe aus sahne und die mondsee
ist ja das typische symbol für den islam
weil wir nach dem mondkalender gehen
deswegen war mit das ganz wichtig ist
wollte ich in irgendeiner form
reinbringen und einen kleinen witzigen
aspekt hat die torte nämlich diesen
dicken mann der ein stück vom kuchen
gegessen ist total platt darum liegt und
falls ihr den machen möchte die
anleitung zeige ich euch ebenfalls in
dem video
ihr könnt es aber auch weglassen und die
torte so an sich machen denn so finde
ich die auch total schön sondern jetzt
nicht ganzen spaß im video
und wir starten jetzt zuallererst mit
den bizkit böden ich bin total stolz auf
meinen bis geboren rezept ich hab da
nämlich auch lange getüftelt bis alles
perfekt ist und die am ende so ein
richtiges oft ein biskuit herausbekommt
aus dem ofen und ich habe auch ganz viel
feedback in letzter zeit dafür bekommen
weil ich verlinke immer wieder auf das
rezept und sagt dann ja einmal dieses
geboren backen und genau so machen wir
es jetzt auch in diesem rezept ich habe
allerdings weil ich die böden etwas
höher haben wollte habe ich das ganze
aufgestockt auf acht eier
ich schreibe euch die genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in die infobox
und auch die anleitung zu dem video das
verlinkt ich mich auch nochmal hin der
infobox so meine bachinger habe ich hier
auf jeweils 20 cm eingestellt falls ihr
nur eine springform habt mit 20 cm
kleinen bakken dann macht es so dass ihr
den teig zweimal zubereitet denn in dem
moment wo wir das alles andere arbeitet
er schon das backpulver also solltet ihr
nicht zu lange warten und ich teile
jetzt die masse hierauf in diese zwei
torten ringer
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr das mit der winkel
palette noch gerade so ein bisschen
glatt streichen
wichtig ist dass ihr eure formen nicht
einfällt höchstens ein backpapier
drunter und mehr braucht es nicht
und jetzt werden die leckeren böden
gebacken im vorgeheizten backofen bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze und ich
sage euch gleich wie lange es bei mir
gedauert hat meine böden haben jetzt
genau 30 minuten gebraucht im ofen
schaut bei euch ob sie vielleicht ein
paar minuten länger oder geringer
brauchen denn jeder ofen backt anders
und macht auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe ich denke dass jetzt ab mit einem
tuch damit dass an der oberfläche nicht
austrocknet und danach können wir sie
nach ungefähr 15 20 minuten vom
tortenring lösen
und jetzt geht es weiter mit einer
richtig leckere frucht schicht und zwar
habe ich mich jetzt für eine mango
orange nicht entschieden
ihr hattet übrigens die wahl auf
instagram hatte nämlich ein vorschlag
das fand ich auch so panne wassermelonen
schicht die zeige ich euch aber dann in
der nächsten torte weil ihr habt für
mango abgestimmt aber ist auch sehr
lecker ich habe es schon probiert also
wir benötigen mango hier habe ich die
tiefgekühlten genommen außerdem
orangensaft und der bringt schon genug
süße mit deswegen brauchen wir keinen
zusätzlichen zucker und zwei packungen
magazine das pflanzliche mittel
bevor ich zeige wie die frucht anlage
funktioniert gehen wir ganz kurz herüber
als zeigt euch was ich vorbereitet habe
und zwar sind das meine beiden
tortenring von eben wichtig ist das ist
jetzt 2 cm kleine einstellt weil die
frucht einlage muss ja in der torte
versteckt sein und nicht außen nach
außen tragen und da habe ich auch noch
das ist auch ganz wichtig
frischhaltefolie auf dem boden begeben
dann können wir das gleich ganz einfach
raus holen und das ganze auf so einen
torten retter gelegt damit ich das auch
recht ganz einfach im kühlschrank rein
und wieder raus holen kann
falls ihr dass es diese ganzen
utensilien nicht da haben sollte dann
ist das gar kein problem
dann nehmt ihr einfach so einen tiefen
teller achtet darauf dass die maße
stimmen das heißt so ungefähr 17 18 cm
und das ganze auch mit frischhaltefolie
aus klein und das ganze zwei mal
so und jetzt darüber zum herr und geben
unsere drei zutaten einmal hier in den
topf
[Musik]
bevor ich den hat jetzt einen schalter
ruhig das erstmal gut um damit die
aktive sich mit der flüssigkeit
vermischt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den herd eingeschaltet
lassen seine aufkochen und ab dem
zeitpunkt wo das auf kocht muss es zwei
ganze minuten lang köcheln wird sich da
am besten ein stop oder anteil machen
und dabei auch gelegentlich umrühren
damit amt obwohl nicht antritt jetzt
sind genau zwei minuten um und jetzt
fühlen wir das ganze um und zwar teilen
wir das dann gleichmäßig auf unsere zeit
back trainer und sind doch zu dass
überall gleichmäßig die mango stücke
drinnen sind damit ich das jetzt nicht
ganz so heißt in den kühlschrank geben
muss lasse ich das so 10 15 minuten
ausdampfen hier auf zimmertemperatur und
dann geht es in den kühlschrank für
ungefähr eineinhalb stunden bis es
richtig schön festes und das merkt ihr
dann auch weil dann könnt ihr das schön
aus der form nehmen und richtig schön
transportieren als nächstes bereiten wir
die leckere füllung zu und wenn mich
schon länger kennt der weiß dass ich
diese filme mich jetzt zu bereite immer
total gerne macht weil die nicht so
schwer ist und also nicht schwer im
magen und auch nicht schwer zuzubereiten
und ich sage euch erstmal die zutaten
hier haben wir etwas schlagsahne etwas
also ja ein bisschen viel für die menge
die wir machen aber die recht auch für
viele leute dann brauchen wir frischkäse
und zwar ist das doppel rahmen
frischkäse der schmeckt am besten etwas
zitronensaft vanille extrakt dann haben
wir hier seine standmiete und etwas
puderzucker zum süßen ich benutze jetzt
die küchenmaschine weil das einfach eine
große menge ist ihr könnt aber auch
gerne wie immer ein handrührgerät
benutzen dann dauert es nur ein paar
minuten länger als eigentlich auch nicht
so schlimm
[Musik]
so wichtig ist dass diese beiden zutaten
ganz frisch aus dem kühlschrank kommen
also richtig schön kalt sind und jetzt
wo ich das erstmal bei niedriger stufe
damit sich die mascarpone mit der sahne
so ein bisschen verbindet und nicht
alles hier durch die küche spritzt also
ganz langsam nur für eine minute
ungefähr
und jetzt gehen wir alle anderen zutaten
mit den so also vanille extrakt
zitronensaft den puderzucker habe ich
geriet und zum schuss sahne stand mittel
und dann erhöhen wir immer langsam die
stufe und schlagen das bis steif ist
[Musik]
und das ist jetzt die fertige creme
hatte ich lange gedauert also total
unkompliziert aber richtig lecker und
ich geb dir jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
das solltet ihr auch unbedingt tun
und die ist auch also die ist relativ
geschmeidig die wird aber nach dem
kühlen noch richtig fest
und jetzt machen wir die coole figur und
zwar habe ich mich hier schon fondant
eingefärbt ich habe hier hautfarben grün
dann habe ich rot schwarz und weiß und
dann habe ich noch ein bisschen zucker
kleber wie ich den hergestellt habe das
schreibe ich euch mal unten in die
infobox falls euch dass ihr zu
kompliziert ist und ihr kein zucker
kleber machen möchte oder nicht da habt
dann könnt ihr auch wasser nehmen also
für die kleine mengen von land reicht
eigentlich wasser vollkommen sonne
zeigen sich schritt für schritt die
anleitungen wir starten zuallererst mit
dem grün von dann das wird der
oberkörper des mannes und das habe ich
hier schon ein wenig tropfen artig
geformt hier oben müsst ihr euch
vorstellen kommt der kopf hin könnt ihr
das hier so ein bisschen abflachen das
ist der runde bauch beziehungsweise ist
ein gewand ein bisschen länger hier
kommen gleich schon direkt die beine
und deshalb könnt ihr das hier unten
auch schon mal so ein bisschen abflachen
übrigens könnt ihr ein bisschen besser
modellieren wenn ihr die hände so ein
bisschen mit kokosfett einfindet dann
rutscht das ein bisschen besser aus dem
oberkörper werden wir jetzt noch die
arme rausschneiden und zwar links und
rechts am besten in der küchen schere
und jetzt jetzt noch aussieht pinguin
deshalb einfach hier nochmal die
amischen rund form und den bauch an den
seiten auch noch mal rund form
[Musik]
so sieht der oberkörper jetzt aus den
einen arm den werde ich dir schon mal
pinsel mit etwas zucker kleber schön in
die achseln genau so und dann legen wir
den darüber denn der fast gleich sein
bauch anmarsch und richtig viel kuchen
gegessen hat es ist es gehe ich hier mit
so einem kleinen beutel einmal rein denn
hier kommen gleich noch die beine rein
als nächstes machen wir den kopf und
dafür habe ich hier die hautfarbe bilden
passte genommen habe mir jetzt so
blitzartig ausgerollt und geformt und da
jetzt hier die stehen viel zu lang ist
und gleich sowieso noch die gebets
müsste drauf kommt werden wir hier von
der stehen die obere seite etwas
abschneiden stadt gar nicht weh
zugleich kommt hier die mütze drauf
deswegen kann das ruhig zu bleiben
vielleicht nur so ein bisschen die
seiten vorn aber das hier sieht man
gleich sowieso nicht mehr
[Musik]
als nächstes machen wir die nase
hierfür nehmen wir uns jetzt auch ein
ganz kleines stück von der blöden passte
und rollen die auch wieder oval
ihr könnt euch hier auch helfen mit
diesem ball toll weil ich finde dass es
dann so einen richtigen nasen optik
macht müsst ihr aber nicht so und ich
werde jetzt hier unten wo die
nasenlöcher sind nehme ich mir jetzt
hier sondern haben sogar mal schnell zur
hand stocker genau wie viele es dort
nicht ein und einfach zwei löcher hier
unten rein machen
jetzt habe ich hier ein wenig zucker
kleber draufgeklebt ihr gesagt es geht
auch wasser das ist auch kein problem
und dann einfach im gesicht platzieren
jetzt schneiden wir hier eine senkrechte
ein für den mund investment im scharfen
messer und dann öffnen wir den mund
klingt ihr euch ein anderes werkzeug und
öffnet das so ein bisschen nach unten
hin
[Musik]
als nächstes ist die zunge dran und die
hängt hier seitlich aus dem mund heraus
[Musik]
so jetzt noch ein doppelkinn und jetzt
machen wir weiter mit den augen und den
augenbrauen
[Musik]
seit mal ehrlich leute wer sieht genauso
aus nach dem essen ihr sind ich glaube
du hast du siehst genauso aus nach dem
essen musikerin ok kommen doch noch
ausgewertet soll jetzt zeige ich euch
wie wir die gesetze machen die geht auch
super einfach dafür habe ich mir einfach
so ein stück weiße blüten passte
genommen und dann einfach zwischen
zeigefinger und daumen so ein bisschen
rein drücken dann kriegt das auch so ein
bisschen die form und dann können wir
das einfach auf den kopf setzen
natürlich mit zucker kleber oder mit
wasser
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit den händen und
den füßen und ihr funktionieren nach dem
gleichen prinzip deshalb habe ich drei
von vieren schon mal vorbereitet aber
bevor wir die füße ankleben brauchen wir
noch die hose
in dem fall habe ich eine weiße rose
genommen ich vorne so ein bisschen mit
dem rollstuhl einfach reingegangen damit
der fuß gleich richtig schön da drin
sitzt und dann hier in unsere
vorbereiteten rundungen einfach rein
kleben so
[Musik]
das ist übrigens der vorteil an den
blüten passte weil ihr könnt dann immer
wieder was verändern das wird nicht
sofort wie fondant und das habe ich
jetzt auch bei den händen und bei den
füßen gehabt ich habe dann ein bisschen
länger gebraucht bis ich wirklich
zufrieden war
das ist schon sehr also das filigrane
arbeit und das könnt ihr mit verdammt
ähnlich so gut ich nehme jetzt meine
schere nehme ich hier mein fuß den habe
ich mir hier schon so ein bisschen frech
dass man in fußform zurecht modelliert
man erkennt schon ein bisschen und jetzt
einfach viermal einschneidend für die 10
[Musik]
und weil die füße jetzt so viel zu dick
und unförmig sind nehmt euch einfach ein
scharfes messer und schneidet die ein
bisschen dünner
jetzt kriegt dann noch ein stück kuchen
in die hand da zeige ich euch wie ich
das gemacht habe
also einmal die farbe eurer wahl und
damit dass so eine schicht ist nämlich
noch ein bisschen weißen reis komplette
passte und nochmal die ausgangs farbe
dann wird das ganz einfach in ein
dreieck so ein stück kuchen geschnitten
darüber dann noch ein sahnehäubchen und
eine kirsche und dann ist das
kuchenstück so eigentlich auch schon
fertig und jetzt gehen wir ihm das noch
hier in die hand und wer möchte kann das
auch noch mal an kleben damit das jetzt
nicht so aussieht wie ein tatort so
sieht das nämlich gut aus nehme ich mal
ein zahnstocher den habe ich durch
getrennt damit ihr nicht so lang ist und
nicht heraus ragt am kopf tut den in
meinen kleber geht auch ohne aber so ist
einfach stabiler und dann befestigt ihr
den kopf mit dem körper mit hilfe dieses
zahnstochers
[Musik]
so zum stabil halten einfach irgendeinen
gegenstand dagegen heißt und dann
trocknet das schon so na klar ich sehe
darin dein spiegelbild und jetzt wenn
wir die torte zusammenstellen meine
böten die waren jetzt im kühlschrank in
frischhaltefolie eingewickelt damit sie
nicht austrocknen und sie sind jeweils
viereinhalb zentimeter hoch geworden
jetzt habe ich meine torten säge auf
zwei zentimeter hoch eingestellt und
werde jetzt immer hier zwei böden
ausschneiden
[Musik]
meine sache habe ich jetzt gerade erst
aus dem kühlschrank holt damit die
richtig schön kühl ist und hier kann ich
auch diese frucht master die mango
frucht anlage entfernt vom tortenring
dies auch schon schön hart geworden und
jetzt starten wir indem wir einmal
unsere drehbare tortenplatte nehmen
damit kann man einfach besser arbeiten
dann entweder handelnden tortenplatte
oder so ein kickboard darauf geben und
jetzt kommt der allererste boden darüber
ich gebe den boden jetzt extra hier an
den rand weil meine figur hierhin kommen
werde die torte nach macht und diese
figur der kann das natürlich auch mittig
platzieren und jetzt geben wir
zuallererst eine dünne schicht von
unserer sonne kann darüber jetzt kommt
darüber unsere erste frucht anlage und
schaut mal wie schön das aussieht
[Musik]
eine frucht anlage ist jetzt in der
torte jetzt kommt der nächste boden
drauf und auch diese schicht machen wir
nur die sahne creme drauf ich sag euch
später auch warum denn ich habe so eine
technik entwickelt wie ich hohe torten
an schneidet das zeige ich euch später
[Musik]
jetzt gesehen jetzt ist die zweite mango
orange rot anlage auch drin jetzt nehme
ich hier den letzten boden drehen um
damit die glatte oberfläche oben haben
und gibt das jetzt drauf und jetzt wird
alles ganz dünn mit der sahne
eingestrichen
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir die erste schicht
same drauf die dient er zur krümmel
bindung gleich kommt noch so ein
bisschen farbe ins spiel und dass muss
jetzt aber für 30 minuten gekühlt werden
es ist ganz wichtig damit alles richtig
schön fest wird und durch die schüssel
mit der sahne auch ganz wichtig bis
gleich die torte und die creme hat nicht
die möglichkeit eine halbe stunde im
kühlschrank zu kühlen
ich habe mir auch schon einen teil der
creme weg gelegt weil die brauchen wir
für die deko nämlich für die mondsichel
und hier in die restliche kämen gebe ich
jetzt noch dunkelblaue lebensmittelfarbe
rein
jetzt ist die komplette seiner einmal
richtig schön blau eingefärbt und jetzt
kommt noch so ein bisschen der trick die
feinheit jetzt nehme ich mir noch ein
bisschen lebensmittelfarbe raus und
verteilt das also für das nicht richtig
um das sie sich komplett auflöst sondern
dass da bewusst noch ein paar stückchen
drinnen bleiben
ich hoffe ihr versteht wie ich das meine
ich zeige euch das mal hier ist
dunkelblau genau ein paar stellen
sondern extra dunkelblau
und jetzt warten wir die komplette blaue
sahne auf unsere torte
[Musik]
und sobald ihr dann zufrieden sein mit
eurer eine streichung mit der form mit
allem könnt ihr weitermachen mit der
mondsichel am anfang gesagt ich habe
mich hier ein bisschen von der creme zur
seite gelegt damit ihr auch schon weiß
bleibt habt ihr neben zwei offene
stellen mit haben die eine größer der
andere kleiner da könnt ihr aber auch
leben was euch am liebsten fältchen so
eine kleine markierung gemacht wo die
mondsichel entlang gehen muss und jetzt
ruft ihr einfach mit den tönen designer
darauf
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die torte eigentlich auch
schon fertig und ich finde sie so schon
wunderschön aus aber die figur braucht
auch noch platz die figur habe ich am
anfang wie schon gesagt die darf nicht
in berührung mit der sonne kommen bzw
legt zu ersten stunde folgen servieren
dazu damit ihr halt nicht durchweicht
also eine gute stunde hätte auf jeden
fall aus und ich schreibe jetzt aber
noch ein tor lag also wo ist etwas mit
meiner zuckerglasur das heißt ich hab da
rede ich habe hier ist apple auch noch
mal laden die infobox einfach ein
frisches ei weißem puder zucker
vermischt und dann habe ich diese
gespritzt so rauskommt und schreibt dass
jetzt einmal auch die skater
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmen wir noch ein stück
kuchen raus nämlich genau das stück was
der herr hier verputzt hat so und das
reicht schon
und fertig ist die torte ich finde die
macht richtig was her und war auch gar
nicht so aufwendig geschmacklich weiß
ich ja schon dass die gut schmeckt ich
hab dir von parteien schon gemacht wie
ich schon erzählt hab ich freue mich
wenn ihr die jetzt fleißig nach macht
wir nehmen jetzt mit zu einer
veranstaltung das heißt wir muss noch
einen kleinen transport überleben aber
so weit ist das nicht ich hab das schon
und ich versuche ich kann es jetzt nicht
versprechen aktuell ich versuche dort
nochmal den anschnitt zu filmen denn da
die torte sehr hoch ist habe ich mir so
eine technik erfunden oder vielleicht
gibt es ja auch schon ich weiß nicht ich
schneide die nehmen sie immer schön
durch dennis schön lang und dann wird
die noch mal in der mitte
durchgeschnitten das heißt ich schreibe
euch auch noch mal in die infobox wenn
ich heute abend erfahren habe für wie
viele personen diese torte gereicht hat
so und jetzt verabschiede ich nicht für
euch und wünsche euch ganz viel spaß bis
zum nächsten mal fliege sketchen tschüss
[Musik]
wer ehrlich
möchte ich schneide schön da nicht
aufpasst und fruchtig auch ja und ja
toll sagte haben sagt oder schmeckt so
gut das ist doch nie beim mango frucht
anlage machen was machen wir denn jetzt
haben okay wir machen ihr habt in der
hand ihr dürft entscheiden mango frucht
einlage oder wassermelone frucht
[Musik]